[Music]
when it comes to sames there are many
ways to become a popular celebrity and
it doesn't always include a bunch of
hard work some celebs work their butts
off to become household names while
others seem to become famous out of
nowhere
if you're new to our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we'll be showing you ten people who
became famous overnight Justin Bieber
but more he had millions of fans
screaming his name Justin Bieber was
just your typical teenager he still had
a love for music and his mom would post
videos of him performing on YouTube to
share with their family and friends but
random internet users stumbled across
the videos and immediately fell in love
with Justin's voice and of course his
impeccably styled hair a talent manager
saw one of Justin's videos and he
immediately flew him out to Atlanta
Georgia to meet with some bigwigs in the
industry shortly thereafter Justin had
signed his first record deal and became
an overnight celebrity Alex Lee it was
just another typical day for Alex Lee
who worked as a cashier at Target a
customer took his picture as he bagged
her items and she posted the image on
Twitter Alex's photos then went viral
thanks to his good looks due to all the
attention he quit his job at the retail
store and before he knew it he was
making an appearance on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show he's now pursuing a music
career and has hundreds of thousands of
followers on social media who just can't
get enough of him Jennifer Lawrence
Jennifer Lawrence had a solid acting
career including a breakthrough
performance in the 2010 film Winter's
Bone but it wasn't until four years
later when she appeared in The Hunger
Games that she became a household name
going from being virtually unknown to
being one of the top actresses in the
industry was a huge adjustment for the
star in an interview with Vogue magazine
she says she's not okay with the
downside of Fame and she'll probably
never find peace with it can bone can
bone put on his red sweater and headed
out to the 2016 presidential debate
between Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
to ask a question about energy policies
his calm and gentle voice as well as his
outfit put the limelight on Ken who is
later crowned the true winner of the
debate Halloween costumes featuring his
red sweater immediately hit store
shelves and Ken went on a media tour to
make guest appearances on CNN and Jimmy
Kimmel Live Nick Jonas when Nick Jonas
was six years old he tagged along with
his mom to a beauty salon he began
singing to himself in the salon and a
customer refered Nick and his mom to a
talent manager to help kick-start his
career a year later the young boy was
starring in a Broadway production and
soon after he and his brothers snagged a
recording contract for their group the
Jonas Brothers / Nick Fame just seemed
to fall right into his lab Jacob
Sartorius when the social network
musically launched in 2014 it
immediately became one of the most
popular sites to create fun music videos
Jacob Sartorius was just one of the
millions of registered users who would
post their lip-synching videos on the
app but Jacobs content stood out above
the rest and he's now signed a record
deal of his own he went from recording
videos in his home to performing in
front of thousands of people on his the
last text music tour Matt Dillon before
appearing on the TV show wayward Pines
and landing a role in the comedy there's
something about Mary
Matt Dillon was living the life of a
typical teen one day while he was in the
middle of cutting class he was
approached by producers of a low-budget
film who were on campus looking for
child actors they offered
fourteen-year-old Matt a role in their
film and he gladly accepted it wasn't
long after that he became one of
Hollywood's most sought-after actors
Robert Pattinson no one really knew who
Robert Pattinson was until he was cast
in the box-office hit Twilight almost
immediately Robert became a household
name and girls all over the world had
his pictures and posters covering their
bedroom walls thanks to the Twilight
series
Robert has since gone to be a megastar
in the entertainment industry Kim
Kardashian as Paris Hilton's best friend
and assistant Kim Kardashian was able to
tag along to the trendiest nightclubs
and industry parties but it wasn't until
Kim's adult film was released that she
became insanely popular the attention
she received from the film catapulted
her reality television career
in the blink of an eye she went from
being Paras and sidekicks to being the
star of her own television series she
has appeared on the covers of hundreds
of magazines has been interviewed by
almost every television station and
she's capitalized on her success by
signing lucrative makeup clothing mobile
app and footwear endorsements Danielle
pergola in 2016 Daniele Peugeot Li was
an out-of-control teen who has given her
mother a hard time she appeared on the
dr. Phil show to discuss her bad
behavior and after telling the show's
audience to cash me outside how about
that she became an instant celebrity she
now charges up to $40,000 to make an
appearance she has appeared in a rap
video and she has also launched a
clothing collection that's dedicated to
her catchphrase have you ever had dreams
of becoming an overnight celebrity let
us know in the comment section down
below and if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to give it a big thumbs up
[Music]